the kremlin will be hoping this long
line of voters can be relied upon to
back united russia the pro vladimir
putin party that wants to hold on to its
super majority in the state duma the
lower house of parliament
they face an hours-long wait on a cold
moscow morning
they could vote at any time in the next
three days the election commission says
they're military personnel coming off
the night shift
a russian independent election
monitoring group golots pointed out the
lack of people in uniform
the thing is that more and more russian
citizens don't believe in the legitimacy
of these elections it's just for show
nobody actually believed in free
elections in the soviet union it just
became accepted for the communists to
get 99 percent of the vote putin wants
to create the same status quo that
united russia will always have a super
majority and people will make peace with
that the only intrigue now is whether
it's only the kremlin that can influence
voters or if smart voting can too
the idea of smart or tactical voting
came from allies of jailed opposition
activist alexei navalny
they've drawn up a list of candidates
most likely to defeat united russia and
so at least deprive the party of its
super majority there's a smart voting
app where you enter your voting district
and it tells you who you should vote for
now the kremlin has told apple and
google that this app is illegal and both
companies have now taken it off their
stores
united russia had just 27 support in
pre-election polls there's widespread
public dissatisfaction with corruption
and poor living standards but the
russian president still enjoys around 60
percent approval vladimir putin is
isolating after coming into contact with
someone who tested positive for covid19
he voted online
as you can see under sanitary
constraints in quarantine i did my civic
duty online in electronic format such
voting system is used in many countries
of the world and has been used in moscow
several times
many polling stations in russia were
like this for much of friday quiet
opposition groups say they want their
supporters to wait until as late as
possible on sunday to vote to reduce the
risk of their ballot being interfered
with
bernard smith al jazeera moscow